Sarah Safari look at the show Hello
thank you for having me how are you good
how are you very good thank you
talk to me about the muscle mummy
movement I'm hearing about it on the
internet that guys there's like a move
away from thin SPO to fits boat and now
muscle mummy which is the step up and
even though you only just heard about
the word today it feels like you're part
of that movement yeah people have been
commenting on like guys comment on my
posts like muscle mommy sometimes and
like
I'm not gonna lie I kind of like it but
today was the first time that I've heard
like women addressing themselves as
muscle mommy or each other as muscle
mommy gymshark did a muscle mommy
t-shirt yes and I was at the event and I
like even you know girls talking on the
intercom or whatever they'd be like okay
muscle mommy's like let's keep pushing
and I was like I've never heard this
like I haven't heard like women
addressing women as Muslim mommies I
thought it was more of like a like kind
of joking flirty type thing that guys
comment on girls posts on Instagram
taking the word and made it your own so
uh
you're 23 22 22.
you probably growing up would have seen
body types change from I guess when you
were maybe 11 12 13 through to now for
sure talk to me about like that ideal
female shape and kind of the lessons
that you talk about what an attractive
woman is yeah physically over time
for me growing up at first I was really
skinny and then through high school like
I would always fluctuate and wait like
I'd go anywhere from 130 pounds to 100
pounds
um which is a pretty big difference when
you already weigh like kind of low
um but I would always be told by my mom
like confidence is what makes you like
most attractive like it's not what you
look like it's who you are and how you
carry yourself sorry and so that's what
you know I was taught growing up but for
me personally if I ever saw a girl with
abs I loved it I loved the look of it I
thought it was like so
I don't know attractive to me like
that's what I was aiming for that's what
I wanted but I never knew how to get
there like I didn't know like oh how
does a girl get abs like I thought it
was just all genetics but no diet comes
into play working out comes into play
so and now does this move you remember
when thigh gaps were a thing when
everybody wanted a thigh gap bro yes I
remember being at lunch in high school
and like girls would look at each other
and be like oh you have it oh you don't
the most toxic thing ever and I remember
like I didn't have one at the time or
like I don't think I ever had one but I
would go home and I'd like beat myself
up about it because like girls would be
pointing out how it's like good to have
a thigh gap and interesting like the
internet's kind of become very obsessed
physically with the way that people
appear like both guys and girls yeah
guys are getting leg lengthening surgery
you've seen this
yeah they get the I'm pretty sure it's
their shins extended they break the shin
stretch it a bit the bone regrows they
break it again and keep on going and
guys can add inches to their height at
my point being that people are like
optimizing for really weird
kind of not arbitrary but they're
optimizing for like weird stuff yeah one
of the things that nobody ever talks
about is that sort of hotness or sex
appeal that people have just from the
way that they hold themselves yeah and
from the way that they act I think that
that has
huge amount of appeal to people even if
you don't want to admit it I think if
someone is confident it can make them
from a six to an eight depending how
they carry themselves I think for sure
it can and obviously online dating and
spending tons of time on Instagram
negates a lot of that you don't get to
see that even in a pose somebody can
pose themselves in a sexy way and not
have the com the confidence to be able
to pull it off face to face and vice
versa yeah for sure
so you have managed to gain quite a bit
of notoriety in a very short space of
time I think the number one
job or occupation that young kids in
America say that they want when they
grow up is influencer or YouTuber uh and
in China it's astronaut or like some
other some other like something that's
way less blame yeah
um
talk to me about this rapid gain in
status for guys there's an obvious
Advantage at least on the surface yeah
more people know me I have status girls
will like me but for a girl to gain
millions of followers in basically no
time at all I know that seems
interesting to me that there's there's
probably more advantages that people
wouldn't see and then some disadvantages
we wouldn't see as well so what's that
being like yeah I think
for me I'm I'm not gonna lie I think the
money has been a great great part of it
but for me I'm not someone who spends my
money on materialistic things like I was
just telling you how I have fake shoes
on like they were 100 bucks you've blown
it to the internet yeah no they know I
think if they know they've watched my
content they know that I don't like
Splurge you know I save all the money I
make like sure maybe when I go to In and
Out I can eat a little bit better like I
can order the fries or order the 4x4
instead of just like the single burger
but for me like the money's nice because
now I know I have the power to you know
if my mom needs a new car I can be the
one that does that for or like you know
we're looking to like moving out maybe
getting a new house I know that I can
pitch in and carry my weight financially
and something like that
um so I think just like not necessarily
physically having the money but having
the Peace of Mind of knowing that you
know I can support myself or my family
and what's the increase in attention
being like you just came from this big
gymshark event that we were both at yeah
and you got swamped by men you say that
90 of your audience is men yeah five
foot three hey five foot four
give me a break
you're you're a small girl that's being
surrounded by a [__] ton of men yeah
like talk to me talk to me about this
like this is this is in some regards
like a nightmare scenario that girls
literally would would hate and then in
other regards this is the price of doing
business for you yeah for me like today
I realized how many people came up and
was like sir like you're really funny I
love your content and I think that's the
best compliment for me to get is being
like Oh you're funny or you know it's
more than just
like
oh it's just like another hot girl on
Instagram posting bikini pictures like
if they find some kind of value for my
content even if it's just humor like
sure I'm not giving anything educational
but if they are laughing while watching
my videos or watching me [__] with
Bradley or you know whatever it is like
that makes me happy because I know like
after I watched like a Danny Duncan
video or a jitty on video like I feel
good you know like I was laughing
through the 10 minute video so
what about the negative sides of the
attention have you had many
I've had some I've had some like
maybe the best not to say them to not
dress like very much attention to those
things but I've had some some weird or
bad experiences with people
um but for the most part it's all been
good I feel like regardless whatever I
involved myself with even if I was you
know using my degree and working a
nine-to-five job it wouldn't all be good
there would still be some bad bad days
there would be you know arguments with
people I work with there would be
downfall uh downfalls in other in other
aspects of you know working at an office
from
eight to five so I'm definitely seeing a
Move online of like uh this uh one of
the dudes from the UK made a video
called The Gym Bro culture 2.0 and he
was talking about the move from the more
like ziz era
exclusive body side stuff to a more
holistic integrated it's life advice
it's an older brother rather than a
party friend type thing
I would be interested I definitely think
if you look at the fitness world for
girls it's still pretty trapped in the
it's all about your condition your tan
the size of the bikini uh and I wonder I
don't know like if you have a
personality as a girl who's also into
fitness whether some people and this is
the same for guys too whether they
almost feel like if I let the weirdest
side out of me that this is going to I
don't have many role models that do that
or if I let the more intellectually
curious side out of me that this isn't
what people want on the internet because
all they want I need to be leaner I need
to be bigger I can't show any
personality and it seems like it feels
to me a little bit like the tides
shifting with that yeah no for sure I
think I think it is Shifting
um I think that you know there's people
on social media I know there's one guy
that works out at zoo culture and he
does not have the traditional body type
like
whatsoever but he is the funniest person
online he is
um super caring like he'll always ask me
like hey I want to do this bit like
would this be okay with you like I want
to be respectful of you would this be
okay with you like it's just he crosses
like all you know he checks all the
boxes to make sure he does does a good
job and he's so funny online his name's
Felipe but he is so funny but in no ways
would you look at him and think oh
that's your typical like influencer
bodybuilder hmm
talk to me about this new trend of girls
tick-tocking guys looking over while
they're doing videos you spend a lot of
time in the gym yeah in the age bracket
you're big on Tick Tock you're big on
social media platforms give me your lay
of the land what do you think about this
trend I I think
I think sometimes guys looking at girls
depending on you know the age Gap
I think the age Gap does matter I think
you know if you're a 22 year old girl
and there's a 25 year old guy like just
you know glancing over here and there
like without like constantly staring you
know might be his way of shooting a shot
or whatever on the other hand if he's 55
years old and like he's just
continuously staring at you
that could be off but then he also might
be looking at you because you have a
camera propped up and he's like what is
this girl doing like I don't know what
this is you know or he might want to try
to not be in the frame
why do you think this is happening why
do you think that this trend is is
occurring like do you think that these
girls actually feel this way
honestly no I don't think I think that
like you know sometimes maybe they catch
it in the moment and they think like oh
this is what's going to make me blow up
because I see myself as a very like I'm
constantly aware of who's looking at me
or my surroundings or whatever or you
know if I'm walking out of the pool and
I see a guy look a little bit too much
I'm like can I help you you know I'm
constantly aware of that but never have
I been around other girls and I see them
being that aware of things
not usually I feel like girls aren't
usually that
that aware of it and I suppose
when you're videoing yourself and you
watch your back and you go oh oh like oh
god oh external awareness almost yeah
yeah so he was the thing that I thought
when that that main huge video went out
and nobody did it and then she did the
apology and a joey swole like found his
new content Arc
um
what happened there was
people that spend a lot of time on the
internet use other stories from the
internet as a guide a guard rail and a
guideline for how they should behave as
well
lots of girls looked at that situation
and if you'd said to me if you just
shown me the video in isolation I
couldn't see the comments I couldn't see
the likes
and said
what do you think's the response to this
it could have gone either way I could
have seen it as a coin toss that the
internet would have flamed the guy and
said that's too much that's out of order
and cited on the sort of victim
hypersensitive side yeah or they could
have gone the way that they did go which
is he looks over three times in 90
seconds you're pointing a camera at him
and you're shorter in your ass yeah what
did you expect and you can't do a glute
Bridge like what do you expect yeah
so what happened the way that I saw it
and this is kind of why it's so
interesting
lots of people that spend a lot of time
on the internet look at situations like
that that are kind of landmark
opportunities for a common scenario to
play out online
and they use the way that that Fallout
occurs as a barometer for how they
should feel if it happens in their life
in future yeah I see yeah because the
pushback was there
lots of girls now realize that oh if a
guy looks over three times in 90 seconds
while I'm doing a glute Bridge maybe
that's the sort of thing that I don't
need to be too concerned about the
problem is it could have gone the other
way and that now lowers the ceiling for
guys to be scared that if they look over
too much whether they mean to or whether
they don't that they're going to be in
trouble but the other one is it makes an
increasingly fragile generation of young
girls who feel victimized and concerned
if a guy does look over well I saw this
video on Tick Tock and the whole
internet said that they need to if this
happens that that's unspeakable and I've
heard about the dangers of me too and I
shouldn't walk alone at home at night
this is too much so it almost you're
almost Outsourcing your anxiety level
to the internet yeah and it's like
purely by fortune and you know like the
way that the internet responded that
that didn't reset most gym girls
expectations that that's something to be
scared or offended by yeah but also
coming from the other you know
other side I I can see myself like if a
guy is squatting I could see myself
looking over not because I'm trying to
hit on him but because I'm like wow like
his form is so good or wow he's breaking
90 degrees or his knees are being pushed
out very well or that's a lot of way
like oh how many reps is he gonna go for
I can I totally do that in a non-like
sexual way whatsoever how do you hit on
guys at the gym have you ever had to do
it
no I'm not saying it's all inbound but
I'm saying that like I don't think the
gym is necessarily where I'd want to be
approached so I don't think I'd want to
approach someone in the gym why wouldn't
you want to be approached in the gym
you're like well it is the only two
hours out of the 24 hours that I get to
enjoy
why what else are you doing for 22 hours
laying in bed doing homework eating true
sleeping
like it's my like two hours of like you
know Friday nights people like you know
go out with their homies have a good
time that's every day for me from the
hours of 11 to 1 at the gym what about
when you finish your Masters what are
you gonna do then
maybe I'll get a PhD I'm kidding well
talk to me about that okay so how much
harder has dating been for you with all
of this attention you can't go it's
gonna be like if you go for dinner with
somebody if you go out on a date with
somebody
the difficulties increased exponentially
and now it's all over Snapchat yeah I
yeah it has made things harder for sure
um especially if like you know the
person you're seeing or you're with
doesn't do what you're doing so they
don't understand that sometimes like for
me like I don't drink but going to an
event
sometimes I have to go because I think
like oh what about the business
connections I could make from going to
that event or the people I could meet or
whatever not in uh you know not in a
relationship intimate way but in a
business relationship type way and I
feel like sometimes it's hard for you
know people that aren't doing this be
like well no you don't have to go to
that or you don't have to go to Vegas
for this or you don't have to go to
Miami for that and I'm like well no I
don't have to but I feel like there
would be connections there if I did go
also I suppose if someone isn't in the
industry they get injected into this
level of surveillance yeah scrutiny that
you have that they didn't sign up for
yeah and now you're like oh why don't we
go see Oppenheimer or whatever and you
go oh by the way people might like come
up and ask you to take a photo of them
with me yeah in other news this episode
is brought to you by cozy Earth we sleep
one third of Our Lives do not spend 33
of your life in anything other than
unbeatably comfortable sheets getting a
good night's sleep is the Ultimate Game
Changer and the sheets that you have are
a massive determinant of just how
comfortable you feel cozy Earth has the
most premium bedding and loungewear that
I've ever found they're made from super
soft viscose from highly sustainable
bamboo temperature regulating so you
will sleep comfortably all year round
and an enhanced weave quality that won't
pill so it's higher quality will last
longer and you'll have a more
comfortable night's sleep and wake up
feeling more rested and revitalized plus
there is a a 10-year warranty on all of
their products that's how confident they
are that they're going to last but don't
just take my word for it Oprah has
chosen cozy Earth as one of her favorite
things for five years in a row now you
can get an exclusive 35 discount
site-wide on everything by going to
cozyearth.com Modern wisdom and using
the code modern wisdom 35 a checkout
cozyearth.com modern wisdom and modern
wisdom a checkout yeah that's
interesting talk to me about guys your
age it's like this a
[__] moral Panic on the internet
about gen Zed men especially they're
pathologically fapping their way through
a Monster Energy fueled video game and
pawn binge like what what a gen Zed guys
like the ones that you either grew up
with or sometimes try and speak to with
regards to dating or or anything what
how do you categorize them how do you
classify them I feel like there's a lot
of growing to do from the ages of from
the age of 22 to like 27 for men and I
think you know 22 year old men just
aren't there yet necessarily and I think
that I am I'm pretty mature for my age
um
and I think the guys that I've counted
for the most part just aren't there yet
they're just immature maybe caught up
with
kind of a younger mindset yeah so what
are they doing like what are they
what are they prioritizing what are they
concerned about I think they prioritize
friends a good amount which isn't a bad
thing I'm just saying friends a lot
partying going out you know drinking
I wonder how much of that's an LA thing
I think a good amount of it might be an
LA thing I think if you go like to a
rural rural town in Kansas maybe it's
not as much yeah
have you heard of slow life strategy do
you know about this low life strategy
yeah so there's a
it seems at the moment based on the data
that
gen Zed both guys and girls a little bit
younger than you
um you would probably be at the very
front of this wave
um getting a driver's license later
moving out of home later uh getting a
job later not partying as much not
drinking as much not taking drugs so
they've got generalized risk aversion
they're not doing the risky things that
previous generations of that age would
but they're also not even really doing
the adult things like the number of
16 to 20 year olds who don't have a
driver's license is the highest ever
really you think covet had like a
pushback in that maybe maybe it could be
that people just became more isolated
stopped if that's your formative of
yours if you're
15 and covet hits and you're 18 and
covered finishes you've just grown up
all you can remember basically being the
person that you are is this hermit at
home playing fortnite or whatever
um
but what it makes me think about is
what when these people do need to grow
up you mentioned young guys could do
with maybe growing up a little bit more
quickly yeah if they want a chance and
it makes me wonder whether that's going
to keep getting pushed further and
further not
I don't know it's uh
I think for me one of the biggest
turn-ons or pluses a guy can have is
being motivated or like dedicated to
something even if that's Plumbing you
know just something that like every day
you want to do and work towards to being
better at you know whether that's the
gym or
a job like Plumbing or being a dentist
or being an astronaut like whatever you
know just something to work towards
rather than just kinda
laying back and like kicking your feet
up and just enjoying day by day I think
it's like that's great and everything
but I think you have to have something
that every day you're trying to improve
drive and motivation and ambition I
think are very sexy and competence as
well yeah like if you can manage to hit
the sweet spot with a partner of someone
who you are attracted to but you admire
as well
holy like you've got a a partner that's
your role model yeah that's an
unbelievably potent cocktail I think for
attraction
um
I didn't I it's so strange to think
about
what that is for girls because you know
guys can just go out and get their drive
and and do the things that typically are
sort of masculine traits be very
interested in what the equivalent is for
a girl you know like what is it that a
guy would find in feminine traits that
they want to absorb into themselves do
you know what I mean I don't know one
time I was on Brad's pod and I was like
oh like I don't Coke or clean and then
everyone was like I still don't live
those comments down I'm like okay I've
been practicing now but I will never
live those comments down like oh like
why would you ever want her she can't
cook or clean Jesus Christ we just get
made like you don't need a wife you need
a maid yeah I was like bro I'm not gonna
I mean I don't think I could ever see
myself doing someone else's laundry
maybe my mother's but my partners never
well you just need to earn a bit more
money and then you can pay the maid
today yeah I'm like bro I'll pay someone
to do it I wasn't opposed to a house
Chef so I think I think I think part of
that is is that they associate a lack of
willingness to do traditional household
things with uh
non-traditional relationship that is
just not going to be as as enjoyable
it's a less feminine uh sort of woman
yeah and the polarity between
masculinity and femininity what the
subtext is I'm not doing the washing
you are yeah right which is and guys are
like oh yeah exactly if you're not doing
it I'm definitely not doing it yeah
right so I do understand and I do think
you know there's lots of talk about
masculinity and stuff like that what
about the other side of the fence are
you seeing challenges that young girls
have with femininity at the moment about
finding their role within the world
whether they should be a Trad wife or a
like a
sex positive sleep around girl party
girl whether it should be a hermit
I don't know I think it's hard
especially with social media and like
most of the girls you see on social
media are like
you know there's there's two sides of it
of course but there's a lot of like
um like sex symbols you see on social
media or even if it's not like sex
symbols you see like these hot beautiful
girls that may or may not have had work
done but in swimsuits or whatever and
for a lot of people it's hard to like
you would never get there but like
that's who you see on a daily basis on
your phone so that's that's what you
want or that's what you want to strive
towards but
yeah so I think it's hard to say what
kind of
what ex like extent to femininity girls
look for but I think it social media
hasn't made it easier it's confusing
it's confusing for sure and look at some
of the role models that were held up as
okay so this is really really where you
know this is someone that's charging
forward and really getting it right
lizzo fighting for girls all over the
place yeah and then the bottom falls out
and it turns out that she's making her
dancers eat bananas out of strippers
vaginas yeah weight shaming all of the
people as this Champion for body
positivity and Ellen DeGeneres as well
turns out that she's a total prick to
work with
um
yeah it's like and it's the people that
you would think that were like the most
understanding that turned out to not be
I don't know whether it's people that
you would think I think it's people that
portray themselves yeah that's precisely
correct yeah people that portray
themselves to be like the most
understanding or accepting of everyone
it's like the senator that's pushing the
hardcore anti-gay legislation that goes
home and secretly watches on VPN right
yeah
um it's I I think it's fascinating and
there's a part of that you know the
because people's actions are way less
visible than their words online like the
thing that you tweet is way more
important than the thing that you did
because no one sees the thing that you
did but they see the thing tweeted yep
so when you look at the people that are
the most forthcoming
about being virtuous or morally Grand
standing or I'm holier than now
when you see that that to me a lot of
the time signals
there's probably something going on
there unless I can really really prove
it and I didn't see it with lizzo not
that I like a lizzo scholar
um but lizzo fan yeah I I didn't look at
her and see
yeah this is someone who's really
working hard to try and find the next
like Frontier for uh female body
empowerment or something like that it
seemed like someone doing a grift it
seemed like someone that had managed to
published that managed to capture a
particular
narrative and was just leaning into it
yeah
Brad vs Logan who wins
yo brow's gonna flame me if I don't say
Rod's gonna win
uh in a street fight no in the ring in
the ring in the boxing okay see you made
it harder that's the fight that they're
talking about no no Brad was talking
about street fight like yo I'm 260 pull
up outside the gym I'll rock your [__]
okay who wins in the street fight Brad
in the ring Logan
managed to pull that fence out if you're
awesome thank you yeah don't kick me off
frog here Brad
I'm kidding but Brad is like
obscenely strong too he's quick he's
stronger than Chris Bumstead right they
had sibo on the podcast and Brad was
like yo don't compare our numbers
because it's not fair I was like Hang on
we're talking about a world champion I
trained with Chris Chris is a and he's
one of those guys that's got big hands
like you dude you've even your hands are
even muscle yeah
um so yeah he is strong but I don't know
I mean Brad better get on that cardio
game if he wants to try and do five or
eight rounds he's strong and he's also
like a weirdly athletic like he can do
like weirdly High Box jobs or like like
I don't know I just
do you think you'd do it do you think he
would actually go for a boxing fight
yeah with Logan
with Logan probably because now Logan
has called him out Brad would look like
a Bradley would look like a wimp if he
didn't but Logan hasn't said that he'll
do it personally he said he had found
someone for Brad to fight right uh I
didn't know I didn't I didn't dig into
the the specifics of it but I know that
they'd had beef yeah and had like
Twitter beef which feels old school for
people that are kind of yeah Instagram
and YouTube Stars I seem so high school
a little bit but
I'd love to see that yeah I think it
would be an insanely like good PR for
both of them they both bring clout to
the table like
everybody oh geez yeah everybody loves
them equally like different camps love
them equally as well which is
interesting
what's your what do you went to the Jake
Paul fight yeah for the week what do you
make of this world of would uh Bryce
just won a bare knuckle fight that was
crazy the first thing that I've ever the
first uh situation I've ever seen Bryce
get into
I didn't even know he's doing bare
knuckle and then he goes up against a
guy who's been doing a good a good bit
and wins yeah he wins I think he
technically wants you to an injury but
he went yeah he won but he called it too
Bryce was like I'm gonna win in round
two and he won in round two
if I play
would you do you want to step in the
ring bare Knuckles no just boxing
I would do boxing I'd fight someone
who'd you wanna who do you want to fight
who'd you hate
there's no have any enemies there's no
one that I hate per se there's been
people I think that have hated me
who's your biggest beef been with
I haven't personally had B who's beefed
with you the most who's beefed with me
yeah
I don't know if I can I don't know I
don't want to bring attention to her go
bro I'm telling you right now I would
cut down to her weight and I'd beat the
[__] out of her
no I'm kidding but I think that um I
would definitely I think it'd be dope to
do like an influencer boxing type thing
like people who haven't fought before
getting in the ring same weight class
you know both had three months six
months training leading up to the fight
and then fighting each other yeah that'd
be dope it doesn't have to be a married
Knuckles like little boxing and it's so
funny how the world of Combat Sports now
has really been reshaped by it right
you've got Francis and ganu and Tyson
Fury fighting each other you know UFC
Legend up against the greatest living
heavyweight fighter potentially the
greatest ever and I don't think that
that would have happened had KSI Logan
Paul not happened yeah had uh Mayweather
McGregor not happened and if you track
it all the way back it's two British
guys forever ever ever ago like yeah
seven or eight years ago or something
that that kicked it all off and now
you've got
who's Logan's next fighter Dylan danis
yeah and then KSI is fighting
some guy I don't know he's like big big
time but I don't know
point being
before it was we can't believe that
these influences are coming in and
ruining the sweet science of boxing yeah
and now Downstream the purest boxing
people uh following the model fighting
the influencers precisely correct right
so funny because I think that at the end
it's a win-win for everyone because more
you know the influencers bring a little
bit a different crowd the younger crowd
they bring a little bit more PR to it
whatever it might be I think they bring
a different audience to it that you know
helps them both sells tickets gets
pay-per-view watches
It's Entertainment as well yeah it's
entertainment and
you know when people say this is getting
like WWE and they're talking about
baseball or they're talking about NFL or
whatever or NBA
I realized this the other week what they
mean is what happened was WWE
essentially took the sport element out
of sport
and all that you had to do was reverse
engineer the best way to create the
Rivalry and then we'll you don't need to
worry about the outcome of the contest
because we already know what's going to
happen because we can write that right
so when people say this is becoming like
WWE what they mean is they found the
model of how to create a rivalry and
this rivalry is starting to look like
that so really all it is is these people
in NBA or whatever
zeroing in on a really really heated
rivalry that compels people I don't
think it's fair necessarily to say this
is becoming like WWE they split tested
for you know decades and decades the
best oh we're gonna have the heel we're
gonna have like the redneck guy we're
gonna have the clean-cut heartthrob
we're gonna have the Renegade artist
we're gonna have the Mexican dude that's
got the Hat the face mask on yes yes
yeah
yeah so you just have this very
effective way at garnering attention in
a sport and you don't need to worry
about the spot and now we're seeing it
get across and you've seen a drive to
survive which is the Formula One Thing
uh full swing which was for golf break
point that was for tennis quarterback
now that's all about uh NFL
and people are interested in what's
going on behind the scenes which is
exactly why you have to post 140
SnapChat photos I guess yeah every
single day people care about more than
just like an Instagram picture here or
there they care about what you're doing
yeah this episode is brought to you by
levels one of the single biggest
predictors of how long you live and how
good you'll feel while living is your
metabolic Health the single best way to
work out how your daily decisions are
impacting your longevity and Your
vitality is by tracking your glucose
this is why I wear a continuous glucose
monitor from levels it allows me to
understand in real time how the foods
that I'm eating are impacting my health
and the way that I feel the levels app
interprets your glucose data and gives
you a score after each meal so that you
can see how different meals are
impacting you and it will give you
personalized diet recommendations that
are right for your body glucose is a
huge determinant of not only Your
vitality and your longevity but of the
way that you feel day to day using
levels means that you take the guesswork
out of this it can help you to nudge
your diet towards something which is
going to be better for you right now and
in the long term as as well after using
levels I realized if I have a large carb
meal and I do not go for a walk
afterwards my blood glucose goes through
the roof and I don't feel so good head
to levels.link slash modern wisdom to
take advantage of an exclusive offer
plus get that 90-day money-back
guarantee that's levels.link slash
modern wisdom I've asked this question
to a bunch of different people
if you only had 10 exercises
for the rest of your life to hold on to
as much muscle or build as much muscle
as you could
which ones would you choose and why 10
exercises 10 exercises can be anything
you want but you've only got ten okay
let's start off leg press okay for
you know you can do different variations
in it you can hit like different parts
depending on how you put your legs
already else
barbell dumbbells single leg
barbell adios is Hardcore okay cool yep
okay
military press
with the barbell military process no
standing so you can brace your core I
mean you only get 10 exercises here okay
right yeah yeah so you've made an ab
exercise out of a shoulder exercise
right good
um incline dumbbells
every single person has said incline
dumbbell press chest press yeah yeah
phenomenal yeah can't go wrong yep
that's full all right
gosh okay what is it decline or incline
I always confuse myself when you lean
back a little bit and you do the curls I
think that's technically incline but I
know exactly what you mean yes because I
always mess it I know what you mean
those curls with dumbbells supinated
so like from neutral to supinated or do
you keep it because some people keep it
locked out like that and I keep it
locked out like that yep yeah so it's
almost like a I think it's called like a
y Co yeah are you here yeah it does suck
so hard and you're so weak on those you
know at the bottom of the movement and
it's you flex your tricep at the bottom
five kilos yeah yeah and then it starts
moving okay that's five so we've got
five leg press
audios with a barbell
military press standing
incline dumbbell chest press yeah with
dumbbells
that last one you just lost whatever
that is okay so halfway through halfway
through smoked your legs are okay
chest's okay shoulders are okay biceps
right a weighted Pull-Ups for back okay
that's I think maybe one of the only
exercises I need overhand underhand
neutral I'm not a [__]
come on overhead okay
Chris Bumstead said neutral oh [__] I
mean neutral right that's six
okay uh
gosh this is hard
hammer curls to hit the other head of
the bicep right okay yeah standing
hammer curls uh-huh it's a lot of biceps
now with the pull-ups with the two sets
of curls okay yeah we're good with
biceps now I think I'm gonna have to do
lateral lateral races for shoulders yep
oh my God I didn't hit any triceps do I
have one more exercise you've got two
left I think two left yeah
um School crushers
yeah tell you what uh I forgot that I
did five years ago and then rediscovered
it the other day uh lying skull crushes
so going to the floor and taking it from
the floor as opposed to going from a
bench because you can go from a dead
stop and it means that if you need to
fail you can always you you're never
scared of literally smashing yourself in
the face yeah falling off the back of
the bench yeah uh and it feels really
comfy you know sometimes if you bring
your feet up on a bench and you feel
like you wobbly a little bit yeah
um
yeah okay skull crushes so you got one
left
from all of that
and then I think I'm gonna have to do
hanging leg raises perhaps yeah that's
the most popular ABS exercise as well
yeah Ryan Terry uh
uh Chris Bumstead both of them it's one
of those weird things everyone trains
everyone's kind of got a confusion
around training abs and all the people
that have got good midsections yeah
everyone always asks me what's your like
ab workout and I'm like maybe once a
week I'll either hit decline sit-ups you
know with like a weight with 10 pounds
or I'll do hanging leg raises but
um most of it is just like even bracing
my core and any other workout
um I do vacuums or just what you eat
well you I think you came into training
pretty under fed yes right crazy crazy
talk through that like where you were at
body wise and then sort of your
progression of training in the gym yeah
so I was going through a hard time I was
like the lowest I'd ever weighed I was
100 pounds and I was very insecure with
myself
um I would always wear baggy clothes
because I hated how like I felt like I
just looked sick like that's how skinny
I was I remember my meals would like a
McDonald's little burger like off the
dollar menu and a large Coke would be my
meal for the day
that's all you did that's all I would
eat I remember at 7 pm usually I'd get
up and go get that and then drive around
the town for an hour and go back home
like my mental health just was so
poop it was crappy
and I think that went on for about six
months and then
I was it was just like
a switch I was tired of spending
literally every hour in bed and like
just moping around low energy low
confidence and then I was like you know
what like I have nothing better to do
might as well hit the gym was there a
moment was it oh is it just a
progression over time of becoming
increasingly fed up with that
I don't think there was a moment per se
but I think I just got tired of feeling
so shitty
like I was tired of feeling tired and
and like I was just so unhappy with
myself how old are we I was 20.
yeah about two years ago 20.
um
and then I remember I literally remember
like what I was wearing that day and I
remember the drive to the gym to sign up
for the gym membership
um I remember I wore glasses I didn't
think like I was like I'll get the
membership today and I'll start tomorrow
or whatever I went in I got the
membership and then I started that same
day I wore my glasses to work out
whatever I just it was weird but I
remember it
and then um I worked out and then I went
home and I was like well I had seen tick
tocks like right after you work out you
have to eat something like high protein
like I'm gonna eat like half a piece of
salmon
and I was like anything is better than
like a McDonald's burger at this point
so I remember I was just like I would
learn a little bit on Tick Tock I'd
learned a little bit from my brother I'd
learn like people that just work out I
would talk to them try to pick their
brain about like how I can improve like
everything all at once like my nutrition
my workouts everything so it was just
like a mix of tick tock talking to
people that helped me kind of get to
where I am and within like maybe six
seven weeks of working out I think I
really had it dialed so I picked it up
very
fast relatively you know trained with
intensity from the beginning
um would push myself
I remember it was when I started like
you just have to wear face masks at the
gym I'm about like sometimes I would
have like
oh [__] yeah so this was during covert
yeah it was 2020 when I started it was
uh May of 2020.
in the midst of it yeah
wait may have 2020 or 2021
might be 20 21. I think it was 2021
still in the midst of that yeah
it was 2021 yes yeah
what was most difficult what advice
would you give to girls that are unhappy
with their body or guys that are unhappy
with their bodies like you know there's
a lot of challenges and overcoming
there's a lot of even if you did get
some advice from Tick Tock yeah most of
it is horse [__] regardless of who you
are I think you need to implement some
type of physical activity for an hour
and a half a day
you know 45 minutes to an hour and a
half depending on the level of intensity
but whoever you are however old you are
even if that means going outside and
walking you know
um for me it's like the gym is something
that it's not a chore it's gotten to the
point that it's the two hours of the day
that I enjoy like I was telling you
earlier like I look forward to like
going to the gym
um regardless of your age you need to
work out do some kind of physical
activity train with intensity whatever
train on your own yeah because obviously
in a lot of the content that you put
online there's it'll Brad you guys will
be around or there's a videographer
right yes right
um
I prefer training on my own there was a
point when I first started I would be
like there's no way in hell I'm going to
the gym by myself like this is Peak
embarrassment I need someone there which
is totally fine like do that go with a
go with a friend or go with a brother or
sister or parent or whoever
um
but I'm at the point now where I like
training alone you know I
it's like my alone time I don't know I
enjoy on my own that when I do film or
whatever it's like usually my rest day
and I'll go and I'll film at zoo a
YouTube video uh okay because if you
filmed on a training day you'd have to
sacrifice training to get the content
right yeah so I just go on no training
there's no pressure exactly right
what are you doing outside of that
outside of working out
um I sleep about 10 hours a night is
that strategic or do you just strategic
muscle grows in your sleep okay yeah but
10 hours is like
it's pretty intense
yeah but I don't know how many 22 year
olds
million plus influences are saying and I
sleep 10 hours a night and then train
for two hours a day it matters guys
sleep matters okay okay eight to ten
it's not always ten but it's usually
it's never when you join the whoop team
I'll know and you can't lie to me
anymore okay perfect no it's always
at least eight never never lost okay
um
I do still go to school I only have
eight weeks left
so I do that in my free time I I'm not
gonna lie to you I'm on my phone
probably eight to ten hours a day what
are you doing
I'm uh mindlessly scrolling and I try to
trick myself thinking like I respond to
emails I respond to emails like use it
for work too yeah it's work too but I
also convinced myself that if I keep
scrolling something will inspire me have
you got your screen time let me see do
you track screen time on that you know
in the settings yeah I want to see
God I'm this is going to be embarrassing
I want to see the app breakdown of
what's Happening Here
it's actually down from last week so
let's not be too judgmental daily
average is 7 hours and six minutes
he peaked with
uh Sunday's a big day Sundays Sunday's
nearly 12 hours
uh see all activity okay so messages 13
hours Instagram 10 hours Snapchat eight
hours tick tock four hours Safari mail
YouTube
messages
group chats no I mean maybe talking to
[__] shitty business people not all
shitty but some shitty yes many shitty
business many shitty business people
that's what I I was so dumb to like when
I first started thinking like anyone had
my best interest at her or like just
wanted to genuinely help
why I don't know I feel like a lot of
people try to
scare not scam but finesse finesse yeah
such a good word
um I wonder how much of it is the way
that you present as well it's like a
relatively
friendly
girly girl and someone sees this
opportunity to try and outwit uh yeah 21
22 year old who probably doesn't have
really any idea what's going on and I
wonder whether the equivalent thing
would happen with a dude it doesn't I
feel like in social media fitness space
I feel like
from what I've heard and everything
maybe men get you know respected a
little bit more I think they'd probably
get it's harder to break through and get
paid because the way that you can
monetize
good looking girls especially in the
fitness space can monetize guys and
girls good looking guys really only
monetize guys
yes but then I feel like you're right in
the monetization aspect but also in the
brand partnership aspect I think guys
are treated a little bit
better in terms of packages in terms of
money yeah yeah that's interesting I
think just more
respected even personally I haven't had
an experience with the brands I work
with but I'm saying I've heard my
friends like you know due to their
engagement or whatever she like she
should be getting paid more and then I
know a guy is below her on engagement
following everything
and he's getting paid more all more than
she is and I'm like well this is just
she's getting finesse yeah it's an
interesting one I mean I read this stat
the other day that said by 2030 women
are going to control 50 of global
Capital so women are already 80 of
consumer purchases yeah I think that's
skewed a lot because
if mothers are having to do the shop
yeah of course you know every mother is
going to be the one in charge of
shopping for baby stuff and then plus
they're going to get the groceries
inside it does kind of skew that number
um but increasingly I think women are
going to have the
spending power
which means that the way that marketing
stun's gonna happen it's gonna have to
be adapted it's definitely gonna have to
be adapted and I think we're already
seeing it I think you know Brands like
Bud Light Miller Lite you know have
tried to do something that seems more
Pro female but remember what we were
saying before like we can call it the
lizzo effect of
doing something that looks ostensibly
the window shopping is yeah we care
behind the scenes I don't think anybody
really thought that Bud Light cared
about Dylan Mulvaney or that Miller like
cared about the fact that they used to
do a mud
wrestling ad right
I think they saw it as I mean the
Dilemma of anything
oh [__] it I'll say it
a lot of people had a problem with the
dill Mill of anything because
it was Bud Light finally showing the
like woke
cooked blue pill bonafide's that they've
been hiding from everybody all along
but the group of people
who largely were saying that are also a
group of people that will say things
like
don't cancel Jordan Peterson because of
one bad thing that he said yeah so don't
judge some of my favorite content
creators based on one out of context
small sample but then they're flipping
it and judging a brand that's been
around for decades and does this one
thing and maybe maybe they're right and
I'm open to them being right yeah that
Bud Light secretly did hate all
every straight person on the planet they
hated them for decades and they were
just waiting for the opportunity or
a small gifting to a poorly chosen
influencer who's
not super popular amongst a very very
large cohort of the country
was given some cans with their face on
them and I think that
like the much less conspiratorial
version of that
seems to be the one that to me is most
likely and if you want to have the grace
of you know don't cancel people for just
one thing that they said
I do think that you should
consider extending that too and now it's
there's a lot it's easy to dunk on it
right and this is an unpopular thing to
say because it's way easy to say but
like when woke and now they're gonna go
broke and yeah now they're doing um it's
like almost trendier to like hop on and
hate rather than be like wait maybe be
reasonable maybe like it was a one-time
thing let's not cancel a whole brand
even though we've been drinking the
product for decades you know I'll just
Kid Rock shot them with an AR-15 like we
don't need to don't get me wrong like I
think it was a shitty move I'm not a fan
of Dylan Mulvaney I don't think that
that person is a
good actor uh but
I also think if you want people to
extend uh like a cancellation refund
request to some of your favorite
influences and some of the cultural
commentators online that you should
probably consider doing it for Brands as
well yeah for sure it's like a
a reasonable position to be in have you
been near any cancellation stuff you
can't get count you just lift things
I don't think I think the closest maybe
was the whole like oh I'm not gonna
learn how to cook or clean no cancel
because she can't make a spaghetti
meatballs I can cook I'm just saying I
can't like cook anything crazy I can
make spaghetti and meatballs you know
you're selling yourself as a as a wifey
now yeah I'm learning I'm trying to Brad
told me I need to hire my equity
or like my stock why are my stock okay
you'll learn how to cook and clean so
then right Brad's coaching you on how to
become a high value woman right
good spaghetti meatballs great at
laundry yeah can sweep the floor blah
blah blah I'm learning yeah that's
that's pretty high value my issue isn't
that I can't do is that like right now I
don't necessarily always have
the drive to do it let's just sweep the
floor and do the laundry and cook
but I'm open I've been learning to cook
and I can look at you trying to salvage
your I'm trying to salvage eligibility
to the entire internet like please
come and take me we'll get back to
talking to Sarah in one minute but first
I need to tell you about gymshark you'll
see me on most of the episodes I record
in my house and here wearing gymshark
because first off it's super comfortable
the quality of it is amazing and I just
love the colors in fact these shorts
these Studio shorts are the greatest
men's shorts ever created I'm absolutely
in love I'm pretty sure I've had this
pair for over a year now they're super
lightweight they're an amazing cut all
of the colors are fantastic also they've
started doing graphic t-shirts you'll
have seen me wearing it on the Chris
bomstad Vlog if you need new gym kit
this is where to go they've got 30 days
of free returns international shipping
plus you can get a 10 discount site-wide
and worldwide on everything from
gymshark with no minimum order also if
you want to see everything that I use
and recommend from gymshark I've got a
super secret product page with all of
the products I like access that by going
to bit.ly shark wisdom that's bit.ly
shark wisdom and the code mw10 will get
you 10 off everything a checkout what
are you hoping to be able to do next
like what would be you've got this
degree that you're about to finish you
can do lots of different things
it seems to me like you're not
you don't want to just
start and only fans or start taking like
booty pictures and and go down that line
no I'd rather just be canceled before I
did any of that or like
you know
deleted off everything right and then do
that
is there ever a temptation to overly
sexualize yourself
no but I can totally for me there's not
genuinely there's not but I can see the
appeal of why there is for women your
likes have gone to like your likes have
plummeted whatever Shadow band whatever
you want to call it so you're like okay
whatever I'll put on a swimsuit turn
around and take a picture by the pool
you know I could see the deal bang with
algorithms back up bro like we have the
likes are back to normal but like I
genuinely think for women
the second you start posting pictures of
you know your ass mostly you know or
like a huge cleavage picks whatever it
is on Instagram pictures of you in a you
know nice covering dress will never
perform as well as they did when you're
posting your ass or tits so I did a
podcast probably about three probably
about three years ago with a female
adult actress in the UK and I was asking
her about the typical career progression
of girls that go into this industry and
she'd been in it for like a decade she's
like a older she'd won awards
I didn't watch either the awards or the
content that was submitted I think it
was like a Sundance Film Festival it
must have been anyway so I was asking
her and she basically said that there's
a hierarchy of
um
intensity to different kinds of porn
scenes so I think it was like solo girl
on girl guy on girl like all the way
down to like anal DP like it it descends
deep uh uh Han not intended
and I kind of feel like there's an
equivalent
uh stack intensity thing to the kind of
content and I don't think that guys can
do the same thing it's like it's a
topless photo for a guy sometimes you
look better like actually you look
better with a shirt on mate and you
could be in good condition but you could
look cool with a shirt on yeah it does
feel to me a little bit like
you know as much as we've got this
women are at 35 of CEOs new CEOs income
in companies January of 2023 were women
so the highest percentage ever uh women
are out earning man between the ages of
21 and 29 women are out educating men
two women for every one man completing a
US college degree by 2030. even though
we have all of that
there's like still a big undercurrent of
sexualization for women and this isn't
I'm not saying like this is the
patriarchy [__] plowing it on them
very often women choose to sexualize
themselves themselves or each other yes
yeah because it's them largely competing
with other women now it may be for the
eyes of men but if you are hoping for
men to not click on a photo that's got
boobs or a bum in it
I think you're fighting against like the
thermodynamics of like
Sexes no 100 and a thousand times I've
heard girls that and I have no hate on
girls that want to do and only fans or
have and only fans it's not like oh you
have an only fans I'm not your friend
it's not that's not what I'm saying I'm
saying it's not for me and there's ways
I feel about it but that doesn't mean
that I'm gonna dislike you or I'm gonna
hate you or judge you for having one
women say that having an of or whatever
is empowering and I think for me it's
just hard to grasp how that can be
empowering when you're chatting with men
all day or having your management chat
with men all day Vietnamese virtual
assistant yeah surprise guys if you're
if you're subscribed to an of and you
think it's her texting you
it's her fat manager yeah it's not her
yeah
yeah I I don't know I I really think
it'll be interesting to reflect on this
period of
monetization for especially women
in 10 years 20 years time and realize
that it was either a brief flash in the
pan or the beginning of a tsunami of
people sexualizing themselves for the
price of a cheeseburger per month I hope
it's
I hope it's not anything that has
longevity to it but I could understand
how it's appealing for a girl that just
has just turned 18 okay fully not
developed in her brain thinks oh my God
I can make five figures a month you know
I have you know I have 20 30k on
Instagram I can make five figures a
month I don't have to go to college I
don't have to be alone for years
um I don't have to go find an actual job
I can post bikini pics and make
equivalent to a teacher or a doctor that
I could understand how that's appealing
you know what's interesting as well I
think I've heard you talk about this
before that it kind of doesn't really
matter what you post on only fans either
because they've tried to do
like comedy on there I think Whitney
Cummings did a roast uh but Christ has
done some uh only fans exclusive content
uh there's a number of girls that I know
who
justify of
um their MO is I post this stuff for
free on Instagram anyway oh yeah
therefore if I just post more a higher
frequency of the same level of nudity on
only fans that's basically I my morals
from Instagram it's already been there
yeah there is nothing different but the
problem it's a branding problem I think
they say that to like you know help
themselves feel like better about it
maybe because it's the for well for me I
can only speak from my end but it's the
idea of a paywall platform you know
getting people's money to show whatever
it is that like for me just wouldn't
click but I wouldn't even if I was
posting only gym content and leggings
and a t-shirt yeah just the idea of
it's an interesting one we're chatting
with someone you know there's been a lot
of the intimacy as well I think that's a
part of it yeah but so you know how
vaping is like every every person is
taking nicotine in some form or another
I was having a conversation the other
day about how vaping has probably oh
Retreat of cigarettes and the ascendancy
of vaping has probably been a net
negative for health because vaping is
way more enjoyable than smoking ever was
yeah it tastes better it's cooler no
smell no one could know exactly all of
this and it doesn't smoking that wasn't
so good I think if you go into the if
you start to educate yourself about
health and fitness lots of people are
pushing back against vaping too but I
don't think that's really broken into
the mainstream just yet so a lot of
people do it
I wonder whether
kind of like how vaping is the thin end
of the wedge for nicotine
uh only fans has become a thin end of
the wedge for
porn and for self-objectification
yeah
I don't know I agree with you that I I
struggle to see how
I I don't know it's a tight line about
the the
I'm liberating myself and this is this
is empowering because you are taking
men's money
but is the price of your nudity
like a Double Whopper from McDonald's
and then if it's Black Friday it's like
six chicken nuggets yeah I don't know I
don't know and I
it's something that I have like I have
concerns about and I haven't really
worked out my opinion on yet about like
what this means long term yeah I think
that's really going to be I think long
term I just think if you start
again I'm not I it sounds like I'm just
[__] on any woman with an only fans
which I'm not I'm just saying it from
the perspective of a girl who's out
there thinking about it I would
recommend to not start one
that's the only thing I'm that's the
only way I'm coming at this I'm not
[__] on anyone that has one I
wouldn't so another thing I wonder what
it does is I'd seen throughout my 20s
girls that were strippers they really
struggled to see their relationship with
men as anything other than transactional
because
150 times a night
they needed to extract resources from
this guy yeah who was down from
Edinburgh or had flown in from Dublin or
something for a stag weekend with the
boys maybe he was married maybe he was
in a relationship maybe he was whatever
and they saw this relationship with
manners
adversarial as transactional a
short-lived and I saw a a struggle in
their personal lives to
ripped themselves out of that and then
if you think okay and that's not even uh
protracted or that intimate
if you don't have the Vietnamese manager
that's messaging all of the people that
you're with and it's actually you that's
doing the uh simp admin probably [__]
with you mentally so how are you able to
determine the line between genuine
emotional connection and like
performative emotional connection do you
know what I mean yeah for sure
yeah I think not just your relationship
with men but like longevity you know
um
especially because it's something like
you know it's not the same as like maybe
a dancer or whatever this is all online
like I feel like it's something you
could never live down and if you're
already an influencer what they're gonna
what people are gonna address you as
like oh the only fans girl
you know it's it's the stigma that comes
across comes with it the title what's
happening with fansley is fancy just
only fansley have you heard of that I
haven't okay so this is like the twitch
streamer equivalent I think I wonder if
it hey there's no way that twitch would
give it partner access or integration or
whatever but
fancy is something else and I'm seeing a
different cohort of people it's mostly
twitch streamers that are doing that
um and I feel like it's the same it's
like private messages and blah blah blah
but yeah I don't know have you have you
seen the new thing like AI the AI Bots
like you pay per minute to talk to
someone and they use your voice from
your videos or your online personality
to chat with someone yes that's the same
thing like yeah I wonder whether
if I was the guy that made only funds is
British right he's from Essex
if I was him when chat GPT came out and
the AI uh image Creator thing
I would have spent as much money as I
could I would have dumped a [__] ton of
cash into no longer being an agency and
instead becoming a tech product because
if you could vertically integrate
yourself back up and not only be the
service that people go through but be
the creators themselves by making the
girls and by creating the chat Bots and
by owning the algorithms and by owning
the servers you cut out I don't know
what the percentage is did it take 10 or
five percent whatever the day only fans
yeah they think a lot more than that I
think what do they take is it 15 or 20
.
Joe you're always on only fun that's all
that you spend your time you're always
talking keep your money out of only fans
and put it into like one of the
the s p you want to put it in the s p i
don't know I'm not very educated with
stocks I wish I was more educated but
whatever Tesla right put in Tesla cool
Elon Muskie get my money what's next for
you what you doing next after uni like
what are you thinking what's in the next
six months to a year what can people
expect six months to a year people can
expect that
maybe I'll post two YouTube videos a
week instead of one no I'm just gonna
consistently keep doing the routine and
like posting schedule that I have been
and then I've kind of always been the
type that you know I go
go with the flow in that aspect and kind
of hope that luck plays out and I maybe
meet someone that we can be mutually
beneficial with that's most of the
reason I even decided to go MBA route
was that maybe one of the companies that
I'm working with now or that I encounter
in the future you know down the line
they'll want me on the back end right
influencer and board member yes maybe
and I could do the back end and the
Forefront you know
that's cool no plans to release a
training plan a diet plan an ebook a
portal because I think
like whatever works for me isn't going
to work for someone else I think I am
blessed with really good genetics
because I don't track macros I don't
um
you know count calories or whatever
I just you know I it took me a while but
I intuitively eat I don't drink alcohol
I don't drink any of my calories
um but
it seems like you're doing pretty well
without that at the moment yeah I don't
think I don't wanna right now it's
something that's fun for me I think the
second I start counting and tracking
it'll become toxic and I'll you got to
be careful we have this conversation a
lot over the last week
if you really really enjoy doing
something
you have to protect your passion and if
you don't
doing the work at the rate that you're
doing at the moment is just going to get
progressively harder yeah over time
and it's
that's fine but it will change the
pursuit from being something that's [__]
like yeah today's uh rest day and
filming day and I'm fired up to do some
skits to oh my God today's rest day and
I still have to work and that framing is
an awful lot and it's okay do you want
to turn this into a labor or do you want
to keep loving it and it's not that you
can't do both but the more that you work
and the more that you monetize the more
hard it's going to become I think yeah
yeah for sure [__] yeah wait what's next
for you
so I've done who are you trying to have
on this podcast a few that you have your
eye on a few that I've got my eye on so
uh have you seen the School of Life
YouTube channel
so it's a big uh big YouTube channel
that did psychology and philosophy it's
got about five six mil Subs it's really
big yeah it's great um and it's run by
this dude called a landabot on uh oh
it's not run by him he's like the
creator of it now he's got this huge
huge huge team and uh he was real
formative for me so if I had a Mount
Rushmore of podcasts influences on my
Awakening yeah John Peterson Sam Harris
Joe Rogan and Alan uh Jordan has been on
twice and he's coming back on Sam has
been on a couple of weeks ago I've been
on Rogan's but I've got this elusive
fourth guy down here and I really really
want to bring him on and he's got a new
book coming out so I'm working super
super hard to try and get him he's in
the UK but that's fine because I can fly
back to the UK so I got that we've got a
week in the UK with some massive massive
UK uh guests that I can't wait to film
with and I'm coming back
I've already said to people that John
Peterson will be coming back on at some
point this year so that's gonna be very
interesting got lots to talk about
a couple of returning guests a couple of
new ones but this weekend's been great
you know I did this Alex homozy
yesterday Phil Heath and Rich Roll this
morning Stan efferding you today
tomorrow Eric Weinstein who is like this
Super Genius MD at teal Capital very
interesting dude uh so it's good like
things are happening and and it really
does feel like we've got the world at
our feet at the moment and kind of
holding on for dear life a little bit no
that's amazing you're gonna you're gonna
kill it thank you for having me on I'm
honored after all those people you named
I'm honored you had no I'm honored that
you had me on so thank you I appreciate
it where should people go they want to
follow you check out your stuff
Instagram share Safari what do you want
Snapchat same service yeah serious
foreign
I appreciate you thank you thank you I
appreciate it thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that episode
with Sarah then press here for a full
length two-hour podcast with Mr Olympia
classic physique Chris Bumstead